حضره القاضي من الادلاء بتعليقات تعرض
سياده القانون للخطر لكن ترامب لم يستمع
ولم يهدا بل خرج بعدها بساعه قليله بخطاب
وصفه وانصاره بالناريه انتقد فيه مدعي
عاما منهتا والقاضي هو المرشان الا ان
السؤال الابرز هنا ماذا سيحصل بعد الجلسه
الاولى من المحاكمه التاريخيه
بعدما نفت ترامب التهم 34 التي وجهها له
القاضي مرشان سيكون امام فريقه القانوني
حتى الثامن من اغسطس المقبل لتقديم اي
التماسات فيما سترد النيابه العامه عليها
بحلول التاسع عشر من سبتمبر كما سيصدر
القاضي حكما بشان هذه الالتماسات في جلسه
الاستماع الشخصيه المقبله والمقرر عقدها
في الرابع من ديسمبر في المقابل سيكون
الادعاء ملزما بتسليم الادله التي تم
جمعها كجزء من تحقيقه الاولي الى فريق
الدفاع وذلك خلال 15 يوما من استدعاء
ترامب اي قبل نهايه ابريل الجاري اما
المحاكمه فقد تبدا في يناير عام 2024 لكن
لماذا طلبت ترامب نقله قضيته الى مكان اخر
يقول فريقه ان من هاتن تميل للحزب
الديمقراطي وبالتالي قد لا تكون محاكمه
الرئيس السابق عادله خصوصا ان ترامب نفسه
قال ان القاضي مرشان يكرهه في الوقت ذاته
اقترح ترند نقل القضيه الى الستن ايلاند
في نيويورك والمعروفه بميلها للجمهوريين
اكثر من بقيه مدن الولايه ومع كل ما يحدث
وسيحدث يقول خبراء في القانون انهم
يستبعدون دخول ترامب السجن في حال تمت
ادانته وحتى ولو دخل السجن يمكنه الترشح
للرئاسه فلا شيء دستوريا يمنعه من ذلك